on est sur le dojo régional de
Saint-Denis à champ-fleu on est
aujourd'hui sur un regroupement de
préparation pour les Jeux des îles et
par la même occasion donc le comité de
sélection s'est réuni donc à l'instant
suite au test match qui s'est fait ce
matin pour faire la sélection finale
pour pour les jeux des î
alors pour le groupe euh mieux que les
céchelles euh par équipe on a réussi un
doublé historique c'était vraiment c'est
génialissime donc si on peut faire la
même chose ça serait top en individuel
alors je me rappelle plus du nombre de
médailles mais forcément de faire autant
que les Séchelles il me semble qu'on
avit fait ou neu médailles d'or donc si
on peut en faire une dizaine ça serait
génial avec l'honneur
il faut se battre que je gagne que je
perde je vais donner le maximum et par
équipe c'est pareil jamais perdu en
équipe faut gagnez même si pour nous les
choses sont
claires on ne souhaite pas divulguer
pour l'instant la la liste des
sélectionnés pour un souci de pour pour
les pour les judoc en euxmême quoiin par
que si on annonce la liste maintenant
ils sont peut-être démotivés et ne
seront pas sur les regroupements et pour
par la même occasion pour les équipes
étrangères Maurice Madagascar séchel et
autres sils ont n nos sélectionnés tout
de suite ils pourront faire leurs
équipes eux de leur côté même si je
pense que ça va pas faire grandchose
mais bon RL
salut dans la compétition c'est un jeu
avant tout après il faut être performant
donc euh il y a les stratégies à mettre
en
place